do you feel America is sort of
redeemable biology I mean you've moved
to yeah out of America so do you feel
like
um would there ever be a scenario where
you could see
America being a good place for you to
put your your resources your talent your
time and your money
um I mean obviously like this is a very
complicated topic that's hard to produce
to just a sound bite but I think the
short version is I am have always been
and I'm still in favor of American
values
um I think the particular American state
an establishment has reduced those
values broadly and in particular you
know the uh I mean the US was the UN
Undisputed hyperpower of 1991. with even
moderately good management you could
have had probably a hundred years of
peace and prosperity you know something
like that right and what's happened is
the U.S establishment over the last 30
years has probably blown the biggest
lead in human history
you know San Francisco is being turned
into like this you know open-air drug
Den failed failed City failed City I
mean to the north here I can make it
yeah exactly it's happening here too I
mean then that's right used to be the
last Bastion now there's homeless camps
that stretched for a five square city
blocks and I've had the mayor on my
podcast he's a Democrat Todd Gloria I've
had Republicans on and uh seems like
there's just unwilling to really take on
these these huge challenges which as
you're saying we have the resources I
mean California is the fourth largest
economy in the world now
yeah it's in fact actually in some ways
it's the money is the bad part because
many poor countries around the world
manage basic functional civil order they
have far less money the money is not the
constraint at all it's actually the
wrong belief system and it took me a
while to understand what the heck was
going on because you know with Communism
at least I kind of understood it at the
level of okay let's all gang up and Rob
this rich guy and have some ideological
justification for that right Genghis
Khan but with an ideological overlay you
know that's like Stalin right
um so communism at least I didn't agree
with it but I understood it okay with
you know the wokeness that has taken
over these cities I'm like what
political ideology would actually want
to cover a city in feces like that just
seems negative some for everybody that
that's not even like you know yeah
communism at least Market it as zero-sum
okay we will all rise while we rob this
rich guy you know who I see rich I I get
that even though I think it's bad
because I think it's actually negative
sum what actually happens is the poor
and the rich guy both end up in the
gulak you know everybody loses you know
um but with with what this was like why
do people want to like cover the streets
and poop that seems obviously the bad
then I realized that actually a lot of
these activists you know and that's
actually where it's a big part of what's
driven by
and they have this mental model that oh
some Captain of industry walks out of
his high rise and he steps in poop and
now he understands the plight of those
who he's normally pushed out of sight if
you notice when we talk about the
homeless Hill you know the um these
folks will say oh I'm so sorry it's
visible to you huh you know as if it had
just existed and uh now it's suddenly
being made visible to you as opposed to
what's actually happened which is that
uh the provision of syringes and quote
safe injection sites and so on has
actually created a gigantic class of
folks who are either drug abusers and or
mentally ill and or uh you know have
some issue where you know that you know
you can you can decompose the quote
Homeless Problem the word doesn't
actually Encompass it there's folks who
are addicted to drugs there's folks who
are mentally ill there's folks who are
criminals there's folks who just want to
like you know live on the streets and
just have you know a handout or whatever
have you and then there's folks who are
genuinely forever reason down on their
luck and living in a car or a van
um but that last group is not the same
as someone who will just you know
poop on the street and smash somebody
with a different populations yeah it's
different populations right and actually
the term quote homeless conflates fair
you know fairly different things so so
first of all you're mislabeling it the
word is wrong because you think oh that
means we need to build more houses
housing is not a cure for mental illness
okay girders are you know
just just totally different things
you're conflating two different things
and
um
the uh so so they just have the wrong
Concepts on this and you know once you
realize that this activist is looking
forward to this you know captive
industry being humiliated and seeing the
play the poor finally you realize that
actually what these folks are doing is
they're kind of using the homeless as
native advertising in the following
sense and what does that mean that means
more budget to solve the homeless
problem and it actually means more
budget for syringes and these Billboards
in San Francisco that say something like
um you know snort crack but don't don't
inject it right heroin right yeah say it
go too hard they might be a sponsor of
the podcast so please don't be too harsh
on them
okay sure fine so so no overdose right
um change it up uh injecting drugs
carries the highest risk of overdose so
try smoking or snorting instead okay and
crop rotation crop rotation
yeah they put these on buses and of
course that you know like this is
marketed as being actually you know
being real come on man obviously you
know it's naive to say people won't use
drugs so therefore we just need to kind
of meet reality where it is and so on
this is like the total opposite of
people being like you know oh okay uh
everyone's going to be racist so
therefore we just kind of need to meet
reality where it is on this right so on
something that's like saying like a wife
you know her husband's going out of town
and she says oh you know in case you
cheat on me please use a condom I mean
well right basically it's something
which is like you know they are
um the what's actually happening and
this is a key step in this whole cycle
that I had to realize that Homeless
industrial complex
when it gets budget it increases the
size of the homeless problems right well
that's right in fact it's opposite what
happens is the number of put activists
and this homeless industrial complex has
grown with the homeless population
itself so it's to feed the pigeon
Society look at all these pigeons oh my
God and they're actually creating the
problem they are exacerbating the
problem and they are paid to exacerbate
the problem and they are paid to not
understand that they're exasperating the
problem they whether you call it natural
selection I I doubt it's like fully
conscious but their actions are making
the problem worse if they care about
right I mean mental illness is not going
to be cured by you know safe syringes
and uh and drug problems certainly won't
be either but it's like that's the
Band-Aid that you know covers up the uh
you know the the Triangular knife blade
Scar and and it's yeah and like what
would it take to return your business
back to California I mean to be crude
about it
uh I don't know I mean like
what's it what does it take to return
your business back to Detroit what does
it take to return your business back to
like that what how about bringing it
back to Greece or Rome you know like
I think that that era in Civilization is
over and I'm not I'm not like I
shouldn't suppose that you're not happy
yeah yeah yeah yeah no I understand I
understand what you're saying I mean I
can give a recipe I'll come I'll come to
that in a second one thing I want to say
also is basically if you you know one
thing that's recently finally been kind
of featured in The Press is like the
mothers of these drug addicts right
um uh you know like mother of addict
slams you know San Francisco open air
drug policies basically these mothers
are seeing that they're kids who were
borderline their addiction is being
enabled Yeah by this homeless industrial
complex right so that is actually the
angle where you can see this is not
compassionate it's actually zombifying a
previously functional human being in the
name of quote compassion but it's
actually you know turning somebody into
a dependent when they could have
potentially stood on their own feet and
being independent with a different you
know form of intervention right charity
and for in order for to continue they
have to be poor than you they have to be
independent role Etc right so so a huge
part of this stuff is in my view a
combination of gaining status while
having a crew of dependents it's the
same process that that was run overseas
in many of these third world countries
to keep people dependent that's now
being run in American cities now you
might you said what what would be I'd
have to change to come back to
California you know I I gave uh again I
think this is highly implausible but you
know let's just do it for the the
um mental exercise right
um
I you know someone asked me about this
with like the chips thing
um yeah and and I was like you know
because I I was like You Can't Ban your
way to number one okay this is recent
thing where you say you know and it's
like how to become number one in Tech
okay here's some obvious points
for stem education not math is white
supremacy for technology you know like a
Pro-Tech culture not lol Tech bro right
for skilled immigration not like
multi-hundred day Visa delays for like
basic things you know you can't even get
like a B1 or whatever yeah no no but
actually different HIV is like a
permanent work visa yeah E1 is just like
a visitor Visa right at itself there's
100-day delays to attend a conference
you're not even trying to immigrate to
attend a conference is huge pain right
um Pro wealth creation not abolish
billionaires right pro-civilization not
what's happening in San Francisco right
and I I think unfortunately I mean
civilizations have like a like a
heartbeat you know and in different ways
like China and India and other
civilizations are like on the rise and
like look blue America is just fundament
in some fundamental ways on this client
in some ways they're still actually
they've got something I mean what do I
actually think happens it's possible
this is the somewhat dystopian outcome
and that's something very dystopian
outcome which is
you know San Francisco actually hasn't
been pushed to the limit of what it
could be if you take it to the Limit you
have a few Engineers coding AI in their
rooms with you know doordash being
delivered and outside a you know sea of
fatherless drug addicted zombies that
you know these ngos are getting addicted
on syringes like how far can you push
that right San Francisco is like running
the experiment of like you know like
basically turning a previously
functional City into Shanty towns and a
few tech people right I don't think the
tech people are causing that I think
they managed to survive despite that I
think it's the ngos I think it's the
government the state that is causing
that but the tech people are indirectly
subsidizing it by being present and by
paying they are themselves enabling the
enablers right they're by living in San
Francisco you are voting for more San
Francisco
this was just a teaser to make sure you
don't miss the full episode of biology
click here and subscribe and don't
forget to hit the notification Bell
[Music]
[Music]